hello and welcome to this video i'm
playing a swap with black always have
wide against why we don't know what what
is he playing I place this stuff yeah I
member as I had some games against him
so what was the critical line here
castles castles if i remember correctly
yeah that was played in the stem game of
this line cuz far off with white versus
lego from 1997 if i'm not mistaken and
at the time Kasparov evaluated the
position is clearly better for white but
if you check it nowadays with with
computers computer sound will evaluate
the position differently in term and
think it's about equal this is difficult
to say but it's definitely in an
interesting position okay I'm thinking
about 94 here 92 wasn't played in those
cinders in this original game Nyjah for
Queen takes Queen f2 checking d 1 d 5
those kind of things but it doesn't seem
like it should be enough
okay I'm so I'm going back 37 yeah white
has gained quite some space but he also
has weakened himself a bit so the
situation is not not entirely clear this
one ok Knight f6 looks strange ok maybe
have six it's not exactly what I was
aiming at but doesn't seem to be bad so
I would like to go d fire but he has 85
possibly ok Queen f7 maybe that's not
not too threatening ok I need to need
some square for the night ok just long
castles can Bishop e3 is a very crude
threat but you never know sometimes ok
it's not a huge threat can even go Rupe
to two end reply now I put in the bishop
put in the rukon the half-open far
shouldn't be that bad
mmm Jim they can't go eat five maybe
Bishop 83 is nothing nothing substantial
k goes down
how do i how do I get this coordinate a
little bit better Queen f7 may be
getting out of this this diagonal maybe
Bishop is six can be considered
attacking a tool I was also thinking of
okay ninety-five you five or so it's a
tricky move have I don't know I always
have strange or bad positions against
the sky it's rather rather weird I mean
like in tournament chess I'm quite
clearly the better of the higher rated
player and so on but I'm always
struggling in those blitz games against
him I know sometimes you simply don't
fare well against some some player you
have no clear explanation why that is
okay so here after Bishop before I mean
either positive score in the blitz games
but not not as much as it should be okay
so he doesn't take on e4 which look
critical but this is ok Knight takes
Knight if 5 will happen she takes it's
not exactly ideal but the night hmm ok
let's let's try I cannot even go Bishop
easy what why am I playing with this
does not end and I could play Knight c3
winning the Queen aw come on why am I
playing this nonsense against this guy
all the time you just blonde as his
queen ah
and instead I love ever ever ever
terrible position yeah how annoying
really they give away the Queen yo in
one move and I don't take it I takes you
30 this is tactics from elementary
school and I don't see it
I thought we should be three isn't that
isn't that something check time morning
could be to take special chicks will be
a trick there is no it's nothing here
really believe it I where's the Queen
going to a forum
to a foreign I don't have a move I don't
see move out Queen fo ever been to a
success actually m-maybe we should be
four next and made on H was not far away
I know here here threatens made on end
the Queen
white resigns wow that just night takes
you three yeah okay though hmm we had
this this very sharp opening oh you know
you know what I did wrong I have to go
25 here ha I have to go to d5 mm-hmm
actually confuse the move on now I'm
remembering it's like this yeah this F
for Queenie son this is the line that
the computer says that is unclear equal
whatever at least playable and not Queen
age for ah Wow and here it's not it
wasn't and I was really wondering why
it's 92 all of a sudden possible because
this position really doesn't didn't look
great for me this long route p8 chair
Kim be one Queen f7 and now the engine
gives me five with a clear edge already
can the problem is I cannot take and as
long as this pawn is there you wonder
what what blacks movers light here is
totally limited okay this is what you
plate 96 594 and my idea was takes takes
takes we should be six and I thought
that might be interesting my engine is
completely unimpressed and takes
everything maybe check
the engine evaluation is equal it's a
crazy position we should be six equal
hmm instead he went here and just this
yeah check agreed yeah I'm just worse i
guess but somehow I got back into the
game yeah Queen a4 was my bar much
better than Queens is six and I don't
have anything here check can check but
you just place them and now I'm out of
moves instead of winning that Queen I
got into his trouble and now and now it
gets gets gets funky again I think well
he just overlooked okay six you just
overlooked true k-6 i guess but where is
he going where is he going the Queen
doesn't have many squares really know it
doesn't have any squares it has to go to
a form the engine actually gives this
with them with a good position I am
sorry but with equality misread them the
screen here that's what what about this
okay six yeah now what has to go queen a
six and it's worse and after that Bishop
c5 I'm winning with the meat meat oops
made threat and Queen hanging so we
resigned even though i'm down to 30
seconds well there was a roller coaster
kind of game thanks for watching